[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Conan O'Brien here this is my my video
blog and here's what's happening in my
world I just saw Abraham Lincoln vampire
hunter it was okay but I was distracted
by some of the historical inaccuracies
like there's no way you can kill a
vampire with a silver-coated axe it has
to be solid silver idiots so screw that
movie here's something I'm pretty
psyched about I invented a new food
it's called pickpockets it's where I
take a bunch of hot pockets and I pick
out the filling check it out it takes
like 12 hot pockets to get a meal like
this but it's totally worth it all right
this is a new segment it's called cats
sleeping on dictators cat sleeping on
dictators this is where I show photos of
famous dictators with cute cats sleeping
on top of them Fidel Castro Kim Jong Il
Muammar Gaddafi
this last segment is called lady voices
lady voices this is where I take clips
of guys talking and I change their
voices to lady voices check it out we do
not need an outsourced those who attempt
to poison and destroy my brother took me
back to the first moment you made
something love the benchmark for me is
trying to make my bad we're trying to
make my brothers laugh at the table
that's my latest video blog